un triángulo abc es un triángulo
rectángulo tal que hace es igual a 7
veces igual a 24 y tal que el ángulo en
ce es recto así que como se ve este
triángulo vamos a hacer un dibujo por
acá
digamos que ese es el lado b c vamos a
decir que este es el lado sea y entonces
esto sería el lado a b perfecto entonces
estoy aquí es b
esto de aquí es b
esto de aquí ese y estoy aquí esa de
manera que este es un ángulo recto hace
o sea mide 7
ibc 1024
24 ok luego el punto medio de abs m y de
es el punto que está en el mismo lado de
ave que se y que satisface que ade es
igual a b d es igual a 15 así que para
empezar m es el punto medio del lado ave
por aquí tendría m entonces esta
distancia bm es igual a la distancia a m
estas dos son iguales y luego me dicen
que d es el punto que está a 15 unidades
de veía 15 unidades de a del mismo lado
que se la recta a b divide al plano en
dos regiones
digamos este lado y este otro lado
entonces el hecho de que el punto de
este del mismo lado que se simplemente
me dice que el punto d está digamos por
aquí
de hecho todos los puntos que quitan de
a&b están sobre una recta que es
perpendicular a ave y que pasa por m
entonces vamos a poner el punto d por
aquí y de modo que
de modo que
esta distancia vale 15 y esta distancia
vale 15 decirme lo noto esto es d
esto valió 15 y esto valió 15
perfecto entonces el área del triángulo
cdm cuál es el triángulo cdm pues es
cuál es el triángulo cdm pues es este
triángulo de aquí
este triángulo que estoy poniendo en
verde
este es el triángulo cdm
entonces el área de este triángulo puede
ser expresada como m por raíz de entre p
donde m n&p son enteros positivos tales
que m
son primos relativos y en el no es
divisible por el cuadrado de ningún
primo eso sólo quiere decir que esta
expresión está simplificada lo más
posible así que voy a tener que buscar
el área de este triángulo que estoy
rellenando con verde ok
encuentra m + n p eso es lo que nos pide
el problema bien ahora qué pasa si yo
introduzco coordenadas digamos tomo mi
eje x como la línea sea entonces se
extendía hacia allá esta es mi dirección
x y mi dirección sería la línea se ve
que se extiende hacia allá este es mi
eje y entonces las coordenadas de a si
pongo el origen en c
digamos puedo decir que ese es el punto
cero cero entonces a es el punto 70
porque está en el eje x y además estas
siete unidades del origen el punto b 30
tendría coordenadas 0,24
y el punto m que es el punto medio de
ahí ve simplemente tendría como
coordenadas al promedio de las
coordenadas de ahí ver el promedio de 70
sería 7 medios
y el promedio de 24 y 0 sería 12 muy
bien veamos que podemos hacer con esto
pues el triángulo abc por hipótesis es
un triángulo rectángulo así que lo
primero que se me ocurre es usar el
teorema de pitágoras para encontrar el
lado ave yo sé que 24 al cuadrado 24 al
cuadrado más 7 al cuadrado tiene que ser
igual a la distancia de ave al cuadrado
pero 24 al cuadrado es 576 576 7 al
cuadrado es 49
esto es lo mismo que ave al cuadrado 576
+49 576 más 50 es 626 menos 1 para
llegar a 49 sería 500 625 perdón 625 es
ave al cuadrado
de modo que ave tiene que ser igual a 25
o dicho de otro modo esta instancia la
debe a m es 25 medios que es el punto
medio de ave y esta distancia de a m es
25 medios también ahora otra cosa que
podemos notar es que el triángulo amc el
triángulo amc es un triángulo isósceles
de hecho si nosotros dejáramos caer aquí
una perpendicular llegaríamos al punto
medio del segmento hace eso nos dice que
es un triángulo isósceles entonces este
lado el lado
gm
y este lado también va a valer 25 medios
así que esto también vale 25 medios
ahora ya que tenemos eso podemos
encontrar cuánto vale la longitud del
lado de m pues como decía el punto de
esta sobre una recta que es
perpendicular a la recta a ver todos los
puntos que aquí están del punto b y el
punto a están sobre esa recta así que si
lo que quiero es encontrar esta longitud
pues recuerden que este ángulo efecto y
apliquemos el teorema de pitágoras al
triángulo de m
entonces por pitágoras yo sé que
25 medios al cuadrado 25 medios al
cuadrado que sería la longitud es de
este cateto más de m al cuadrado más de
m al cuadrado es igual a 15 al cuadrado
que es 225
así que qué tengo de aquí pues tengo que
de m al cuadrado
es igual a voy a escribir a 225 con
denominador 4 225 por 4 es 900 así que
225 es lo mismo que 900 cuartos menos 25
entre 2 al cuadrado 25 al cuadrado en
entre 4 y esto cuánto es 900 menos 625
sería lo mismo que 275
entre 4 de modo que la longitud de m va
a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de 275
entre 4 ahora 275 es lo mismo que 25 por
todo esto dividido entre 4 y esto se
simplifica a 5 por raíz de 11 entre 2 de
modo que esta longitud la longitud de m
me lo escribo acá
5 x raíz de 11 entre 2 de modo que para
encontrar el área del triángulo verde lo
único que tengo que hacer es encontrar
el valor de esta altura aquí bueno antes
que nada una pequeña advertencia a pesar
de que parece que esta altura que dibuje
está sobre la línea de realmente s no
tiene por qué ser el caso pero bueno
entonces si yo quiero encontrar esta
altura donde este ángulo sería recto
entonces lo que tengo que hacer es
encontrar este ángulo si yo encuentro
cuánto vale ese ángulo del indec me lo
llamo theta entonces puedo calcular esta
altura a partir del lado de m y el seno
de theta entonces como podría encontrar
ese valor de ese ángulo theta pues
quizás podría aplicar algo así como la
ley de cosenos aunque en este triángulo
en el triángulo de mc me falta el lado
de c
pero podría fijarme en el triángulo de c
m si me fijo en el triángulo bsm me lo
voy a copiar por acá un poco afuera
aquí tengo al lado de ce
ese este sería el lado c m y esto sería
el lado mb bueno quizás se ve un poco un
poco feo pero no importa entonces en
este triángulo este ángulo este ángulo
sería este ángulo de acá que vale teta
más 90 grados este ángulo equivale teta
más 90 grados porque este ángulo vale
teta y acá tenía un ángulo recto este
lado vale 25 medios 25 medios este lado
también vale 25 medios digamos esto sm
esto es b y esto s
esto también vale 25 medios
y esta longitud vale 24 así que a partir
de la ley de cosenos yo creo que puedo
encontrar el ángulo theta bien la ley de
cosenos para el triángulo bsm me dice
que el lado opuesto al ángulo al
cuadrado o sea 24 al cuadrado que es 576
576 debe ser igual a la suma de los
cuadrados de los lados adyacentes al
ángulo que sería el primero vale 25
entre 2 eso al cuadrado más el segundo
al cuadrado que sería otro 25 entre 2 al
cuadrado menos 2 veces el producto de
los lados adyacentes al ángulo que sería
25 entre 2 por 25 entre 2
por el coche no me recorro tantito por
el coseno de el ángulo que en este caso
vale teta más 90 grados y eso tiene que
dar 576 ahora bien nosotros sabemos
que el coseno de x el coseno de un
ángulo x siempre va a ser igual a el
seno de 90 grados menos x
pero si yo sustituyó x igual a teta más
90 grados
entonces obtengo que el coche no detecta
más 90 grados de teta más 90 grados es
igual a el seno
de recorro aún más el seno de 90 grados
menos theta menos 90 grados pero eso
sencillamente es el seno de menos theta
que sabemos que es menos seno de teta
así que puedo cambiar este coseno
detecta más 90 grados x
- seno
de teta
de modo que esta expresión se convierte
en 576 es igual a 25 entre 2 al cuadrado
más 25 entre 2 al cuadrado sería dos
veces 25 entre 2 al cuadrado menos 2
veces
25 entre 2 al cuadrado de nuevo
por menos el seno de theta el menos lo
podría traer aquí al frente y convertir
este menos en un más ventas por menos es
más y aquí simplemente dejar seno de
teta ahora bien esta expresión se
traduce a que 576 es igual a 2 por 25
entre 2 al cuadrado voy a factorizar
esto
por uno más el seno de teta
y ya que tengo en este la expresión
escrita en este modo podría
simplificarlo un poco
y escribirla como 576 es igual a 25 al
cuadrado en 625 2 al cuadrado es 4 un 4
el denominador se cancela cuando este
212 del denominador se cancela con este
2 y obtengo 625 entre 2 por uno más el
seno de teta o dicho de otro modo si
multiplico todo por 2 entre 625 tengo
576 por 2 entre 625 es igual a esto se
cancela y me queda uno más el seno de
teta de dónde
déjenme mejor lo escribo un poco más
abajo de donde el seno de teta
va a ser igual
576 por 23 mil 152 menos este 11 con
denominador 625 sería 625 así que todo
esto entre 625
y esto cuánto es pues vaya tendré que
hacer unas cuentas rápidas aquí 1.152
menos 625 cuánto es
en 5 le presta 1 al 2 se convierte en 12
stores un 4 12 menos cinco es 74 menos
22 11 menos 65 así que el seno de teta
valdría 527 527 entre 625 y realmente
con esto ya casi terminamos el problema
aunque no se den cuenta déjenme copiar
me copiar el triángulo cdm por acá abajo
este es el lado cd
este es el lado de m
y este es el lado c m
algo así se ve el triángulo les pongo
nombres espera se espera de esta hora m
ahora bien nosotros ya sabemos que la
longitud de m es 5 x raíz de 11 entre 25
x raíz de 11 entre 2 y también sabemos
lo acabamos de encontrar que el seno de
este ángulo
el seno este ángulo theta satisface que
el seno de teta seno beteta es igual a
/ 625
y además nosotros también sabemos que la
12 m que aquí se ve un cacho el lado c m
vale 25 entre 225 entre 2 así que bien
si junto a toda esta información
yo puedo calcular cuánto vale esta
altura
puedo calcular cuánto vale esta altura
de aquí h
porque el seno de teta es igual a h
entre la hipotenusa que cinco por raíz
de 11 entre 2 y esto se convierte en h
entre 5 por raíz de 11 entre 2 pero
cuánto vale eso pues y multiplicó todo
esta ecuación por 5 por reid de 11 entre
2 obtengo que que h es igual a 527 entre
625 por 5 por raíz de 11 entre 2 este 5
cancela a este 625 y lo convierte en un
125 y esto se convierte en 527
por raíz de 11
entre 2 por 125 que es 250 y ahora el
área de un triángulo recordemos es un
medio de la base que en este caso vale
25 medios 25 medios la base del
triángulo es el la 12 m por la altura
que vale 527 x raíz de 11
entre 250
y cuánto vale esto pues 25 se cancela a
un factor acá y aquí nos quedaría
simplemente 10 y esto es lo mismo que
527 por raíz de 11 dividido entre dos
por dos es 4 por 10 es 40 ahora noten
que 527 y 40 son primos relativos y que
11 no es divisible por ningún cuadrado
de primo de modo que esta es la
expresión que nos pedían hallar esta es
la expresión en la forma m por raíz de n
entre p así que sólo tenemos que hallar
cuánto vale m más n p
en otras palabras cuánto vale
+ 11 40 527 más 11 sería 538 más 40
sería 578
y ya acabamos